de 66 millones de años mide 8 metros de
largo y pesa 650 kilos visión es el
mayor triceratops conocido del mundo y
va a cruzar el atlántico tras haber sido
vendido al mayor postor entre
interesados de todo el planeta
realmente es todo el mundo desde los
eeuu a oceanía tenemos todo tipo de
perfiles museos fundaciones personas
individuales coleccionistas visión fue
vendido a un coleccionista anónimo
estadounidense por casi 8 millones de
dólares y no es el primer dinosaurio en
subastar sea un precio tan alto éste
tiranosaurios fue vendido por 31
millones de dólares el año pasado una
popular tendencia al alza que ha hecho
sonar la alarma entre algunos
paleontólogos
si esto va a crear un mercado de
búsqueda de dinosaurios también en
sitios que todavía no ha sido excavado
lo que básicamente va a desencadenar un
saqueo sobre todo en especies que van a
resultar muy valoradas porque no serán
conocidas para la ciencia pero estarán
disponibles en el mercado ilegal a donde
más y que visto dado que la mayoría de
museos no pueden competir en estas
subastas confían en la generosidad de
los propietarios para que permitan que
el público general pueda contemplar este
gigante ancestral